there are many many cool Czech mating
patterns and the back ranked checkmate
is one of them I'd like to show you a
few other patterns that really happen a
lot more than you think okay and I was
reading a book from a friend of mine his
name is Mark Dover etske
mark Dover etske is considered one of
the greatest trainers chess trainers in
the whole of Russia okay and for 40
years he's been he's been teaching chess
to grandmasters and beginners and
experts and he's really really good so
he gave me a copy of his book and he
signed it for me and I was just going
through the pages of the book yesterday
and he showed a common a pattern a
checkmating pattern I thought it was
really cool and so I wanted to share it
with you I've set up this position on
the board and why it's whites turn to
play if we look at the position from the
material point of view two knights
against two rooks normally speaking this
is a big favorite for the two rooks the
two rooks are much stronger than the two
knights
however it's white to play and white has
a force checkmating variation yes yes
but which move in this exact position
should white play
okay now let's think about it if we play
the move Knight to f6 check to the king
where on earth can the king go surely
which is a very good move because after
King to g7 noticed that this rook
attacks this Knight and there's no
follow-through to the move Knight f6
check so unfortunately this check
doesn't work we need another move
Charlie Knight to g5 that was the move I
thought of - I thought Knight to g5
check but then I thought what am I going
to do if the King goes here now my queen
is being attacked by the rook my knight
is actually being attacked by the King
didn't like that either
and I thought Knight G fight yes it
meant how which move what would you do
tell me yes and the and that's check to
the king so the Queen would have to take
the rook okay so I thought just as the
class thought I thought to myself well
it's got to be check that's good but
then King G said oh I know it's got to
be check well then King h6 said oh my
goodness white to move and play but he
should not make a check but how could he
threaten checkmate how can white
threaten to make a checkmate he's gonna
have to use his queen that's the only
hint I'm gonna give you you're gonna
have to use your queen
yeah Charlie do you see a good rule is
the boy if the board is a little crooked
I apologize about that the easel is
messed up okay it took me a while as
well but how about this move the Queen
goes to f6 now what move does that this
move Queen f6 threatens checkmate
what's the checkmate threat that that
move makes charlie exactly it threatens
Queen g7 checkmate to the King because
the knight protects the Queen
so with this move Queen f6 now I get it
now I saw the trick what happens if
black captures the knight ah Charlie
very very good the Queen comes to h6
checking the King the knight protects
the Queen so the King cannot capture the
Queen because of the Knights protection
the King would have to drop back to g8
and now yes in there ah Queen H a check
is a very good move as the Queen is
protected by the night but our night the
night yes Charlie yeah
oh that's a pretty cool check mating
pattern right Queen to g6 check to the
king the King cannot go into the corner
because because the knight protects the
corner square
right well that was pretty cool I like
that checkmate very much let's do it
again the Queen comes up the board
threatening the checkmate here the
knight was captured by the pawn which
opened up the sixth rank so we checked
here the king was forced to drop back
and we made a delightful little
checkmate
that's pattern number one let's do
pattern number two check mating pattern
number two so at the start we discover
checks by either Knight weren't good so
we started with the move Queen f6 now
blacks a very clever player black said
aha
I get it you want to checkmate me on g7
I'm going to protect the square so black
played the move rook g8 protecting the
square and then did you have a question
no it's okay okay so now black protect
there's no more Queen g7 checkmate
because the rook could capture the Queen
young man what should white play
okay Queen the g7 check it's not
checkmate because the rook has to take
the Queen bravo Bravo Bravo Knight f6
check mate whoa
how cool is that these two Knights
attack this Knight attacks the king the
King cannot go here to h6 or to h8 why
because of that Knight this knight on f6
checks the king the King cannot go to
this Square g8 because that Square is
protected the king is trapped by its own
forces that rook on g7 and that pawn on
g6 means that black cannot move his king
to either square checkmate
isn't that a pretty pattern well chess
is of course full of these pretty
patterns and checkmates occur in all
kinds of positions in this position
would you raise your hands if you think
white is winning okay
raise your hands if you think the
positions even and it is nothing blair i
like that
let's say the players are really good
okay so for those of you who raised your
hand who thought that white is winning
tell me why you think white is winning
who raised as it's black well it's black
smooth because blacks whites last turn
was to it
the queen with the rook so those of you
who raised your hand who thought that
White was winning go ahead and tell me
why you thought white is winning why is
white winning why is white winning the
point is is the reason that you thought
was white was winning is because he has
two knights black doesn't have two
knights White has two rooks black only
has one rook so from the material point
of view White's killing him the game's
over
it's like man and white should give it
up but black has a move that will soon
force checkmate young man Queen e2 is an
excellent move you bring first of all
your your queen was in capture so you
bring your queen out of capture but if
you bring your queen to e to I don't
know maybe I will develop my bishop
so Queen e2 is a good move but it's not
the best one
if there was a daily prize or you know
the best answer of the class you would
be the winner
very good look what the young gentleman
said Queen takes f1 check that was an
unexpected move right Queen takes f1
check yes exactly
precisely and that's a in fact not only
can the king take it there's no there's
no choice he recaptures the Queen so
White's really happy because he said I
got your queen and you only got a rook
I'm really winning now that black has a
really good move charlie
so we pause right here the bishop checks
the king the King cannot cut move
forwards because of f2 it can't move to
g2 because of the bishops control
correct no e 1 and E 2 are defended by
the rook so in fact what White has no
choice and moves King to g1 young there
check and may in fact this is a back
rank checkmate the one that Bobby
Fischer made famous in his book Bobby
Fischer teaches chess but White's King
is in check to the rook but it has
nowhere to move young men yeah exactly
even though from the starting position
white was winning by a huge material
margin actually I think it's even more
than four points let's see so we have
one two three four pawns so that's four
but we have one two three four five
pawns so the moment black is a pawn up
but the bishops are the same the rooks
are the same the Queen's are the same so
one pawn for black 3:3 for white plus
five six and five is eleven minus 1
white was up by 10 points and still lost
why did white lose this particular
position because you noticed that
White's King is a little bit vulnerable
in other words this pawn was on g3 that
allowed this Czech sacrifice of the
Queen followed by the Czech mating
pattern that we saw how many times in
chess games that you've played as your
opponent had a pawn on g3 it happens to
me a lot so this type of pattern is a
real common check mating pattern yeah I
think you see I had a kind of a rule
when I was starting to play chess my
rule was that I had to make the same
mistake at least twice yeah why that's a
silly rule that here's my thinking the
reason why I had to make
every mistake in chess at least twice is
because I needed to confirm that the
first time it really was a mistake how
could I be sure okay so trust me when I
say if you think about all the mistakes
all the blunders you have ever made in
chess
please rest assured I made them as well
but at least twice I'm going to teach
you a pattern of checkmate that I lost
okay
I'm black and this is a game I lost it's
not that I'm very proud of this game oh
no no no no not at all I'm not proud of
this game in any way I lost the same
game twice you could almost say I lost
this position many times okay so I'm
black and I thought I'm doing really
good okay you tell me when you think I'm
doing badly so he attacked my paw and I
defended my opponent brought out his
bishop this is called the Italian game
or the Italian opening okay I brought
out my bishop what's good for my parents
got to be good for me my opponent has
castled bringing his King into safety we
can see that my opponent's pretty darn
good right he's got his principles down
he's played in the center he's brought
his King in to safety and he's getting
his pieces off the back rank I figured
that's a good idea for me too
I have played the move Knight seven
everybody think this is okay move I I
did I mean I played it I brought my
knight to e7 and I'm preparing to castle
it's not a good move how many of you
think it's okay looks okay to me how
many of you thinks there's a rotten move
like terrible the worst move ever okay
in truth it's a bad move it
but I didn't know that I didn't know
that I thought I developed a night okay
young man do you have a question oh okay
so why my yes active or whatever yeah so
one of the things you might think to
yourselves is at the moment the queen is
on a good diagonal and by moving my
night here
I block my queen in truth the best move
is just to develop your the knight to
its nut most natural square at six yes
and then that's correct
even if I brought my knight here my
Queen's diagonal would be blocked okay I
have one extra square so it's hard to
imagine that this move is so bad because
it it's just a subtle difference a small
difference between the two Knight moves
but yet it makes all the difference in
the world
my opponent played Knight to g5 with his
Bishop and now his Knight is attacking
my pawn
I figured I had that whole thing covered
I had it under control
I played the move castles and at this
exact moment I was really happy because
I thought I had controlled the center I
had developed and I had brought my king
into safety in fact not only is my King
not and safety it's in danger
I want you guys to beat me with a
checkmating pattern and what move should
white play now charlie
whoa Queen to age five
boy I didn't see that one coming like oh
no white play Queen to h5 and I mm-hmm I
felt like oh my gosh
because if my knight had been on this
square Queen h5 would have been a
mistake I would have taken the queen
with a knight on this square on e7 and
not f6 suddenly queen h5 and I'm in
trouble yes young man Queen h7 checkmate
Queen takes h7 because the knight
protect the knight is attacking this
pawn the queen is attacking this pawn
I'm being faced with checkmate
what is my only move what did I do
young man yes h7 h6 so I stopped Queen
takes h7 checkmate and I knew that was
checkmate by the way so I was pretty
good I was proud of myself that I didn't
allow checkmate but now white did
something really good what could he do
Ariana
oooh that's exactly what he did boy did
you hit the nail on the head with that
move oh no now I was shocked oh my
goodness I was shocked and I realized
that the bishop protects the night the
Queen protects the night so I couldn't
capture the night with my rook because I
would lose my rook even though I should
capture the night with I I was so
shocked and surprised I have moved my
queen I moved my queen
now keep in mind I lost this position at
least twice in exactly the same way well
for the moment I was afraid that the
night was going to take my queen which
is why I moved my queen here now it's
your guys to [ __ ] to play tell me what
you think is White's best move young man
yes yes this is an absolute wonderful
move this is a wonderful move night
while my opponent was thinking about
that about his decision I suddenly saw
what you said that oh my gosh
he could play Knight to d6 and that's a
discovered check against my king my king
could it would have to move maybe - H 8
or maybe - h 7 and wherever I move my
King I lose my queen I would be dead yes
yeah but the bishop is making a discover
check so Knight d6 the move that you
said is excellent I would be lost
charlie
that's even better
I was worried about the discovered check
that would win my queen but my opponent
shocked me with yet another superb move
that I didn't see my opponent instead of
taking my queen which I would have done
he took a pond
what's wrong with him he played Knight
takes h6 double-check the bishop attacks
the king this Knight attacks the King
and I thought oh I was so happy I was so
happy because my opponent didn't take my
queen I I mean well I moved my King here
because I was really happy I wasn't
losing my queen I lost two pawns but I
figure now I'm gonna fight back young
man most of the time doubles checks are
very good they're very very strong they
forced the opponent's king to move and
sometimes they are checkmate it's kind
of funny to have a double check
checkmate
double check checkmate
okay but now I'm happy because I'm not a
queen down I who I've lost two pawns but
I'm fighting back what move did my
opponent make now what do you think wait
by the way let me just tell you this
little insight huh I'm attacking your
queen
yay I'm attacking the knight yay
so the Imola at this exact moment I was
really optimistic that I was going to
turn the tables yes young men what
should white play correct Bravo the
knight moves to f7 which blocks my queen
it doesn't allow me to play Queen takes
h5 and the Queen threatens my king with
a discover check I have only one move
one move and one move only he I had to
move my King back to g8 where is the
checkmate young man where is it it's
true very good
Queen to h8 check and mate ah not quite
Queen h7 I'll take it but Queen h8 is
checkmate thanks to the Knights
protection Queen now that just happened
right out of the opening it's like
what's up with that I get checkmated and
I know look at that it's sort of like
wow so that's just a pattern that
happens very often and the reason why
this pattern works it's crazy I know
that the reason why this pattern works
is that black makes
what - your eyes appear to be a very
normal move
he puts as night here when the night
comes here it stops this check mating
pattern that we just saw but when the
night comes here night castles and this
sudden queen h5 moon holy cow over h6
night takes f7 Queen e8 now how many in
the class because I want to know if
you're asleep how many in the class
think the best move for white is to
check and to take the queen nobody
sleeping yeah very good and how many
think night take yeah that's right how
many think Knight takes h6 double check
is the best move very very good again I
have lost with this pattern many many
times okay
I would just like to show you very
quickly if I can
another check mating pattern that I
think is kind of cool
let me show you what's going on in this
particular problem okay
at first at first let's think about
what's going on first of all let's try
to get the understanding of the position
black has a very very threatening
checkmate looking ideas he could play
Queen here check and maybe Queen here
check try to trade Queens White's
two rooks are very menacing and his two
bishops also very very powerful
attacking forces but it appears as if
black has a very good pawn shield thank
you thank you it really looks like White
has a powerful attack it's white to play
but it's not easy to see how White's
going to win which
are you know what you're thinking
exactly that's a wonderful move that
would be my move as well Bishop h6 let's
try to understand why this is such a
beautiful move well in the first place
this rook on Jiwon pins the pawn on g7
so black cannot take the bishop that's
an illegal move that would expose the
King to the rook threat secondly this
wonderful move recommended by our young
you're threatening to play Queen tEG's
g7 checkmate however now it's blacks
turn and black gets to make a move black
would play Queen check the King would
have to move black could play Queen
check forcing the trade of Queens King
has to move and black to take rook and
now you have to think you could take
this pawn with check that would be very
good but why it's not coming out of this
with a checkmate black was able just in
time to defend the threats so we say
that was really really close but missed
by just a smidge just this Mitch so we
need a better move with than Bishop h6
and I like the move Bishop h6 but it
wasn't very forcing young man
what what do you think
Bishop f6 very good there should be a
lot of different ways how to skin the
cat now this move is even better than
our Jones move because now after check
King notice that the bishop and the
Queen defend the square a1 so that that
trading idea will just cost black a look
Arjen ah that's a different so Bishop f6
I can't trade but maybe I can just play
this move so now there's no longer a
threat of playing rook tank g7 okay and
it's kind of hard to see how White's
gonna checkmate now a moment ago when
the bishop was here well g6 Queen g7
checkmate please sign my score sheets
right that would have been good now
unfortunately the bishop and the Queen
are not in the right positions to give a
checkmate so we have to go back it turns
out that while both of these moves are
good White has a better move and Arya
and I heard you and I know what you're
gonna say once more well Queen takes g7
check how many of you considered this
move pretty good normally I would never
consider such a move I like my queen I
didn't like giving up my queen but only
for a pawn but White has an idea let's
see what White's idea is black has no
choice he must accept white sacrifice
Arjen what's the follow up
Bravo
the bishop goes to f6 and we say what
kind of a check is that double check the
King is attacked by the bishop on f6 but
also by the rook so the King cannot move
here to h8 that's illegal
the bishop covers that square the King
cannot go backwards that's illegal
the real covers that square the King has
to go to h6 now while Arjen are already
given as the answer how many of you can
see the checkmate in one not a check now
you see it what is it if you like okay
go ahead
Bravo actually you guys have a lousy
teacher by the way I said it's checkmate
in fact it's not checkmate it's right it
isn't
why isn't a checkmate young man
the king can just sorry sir sorry
decant him aware onion it's a it's it's
a temporary blocking move it's not
checkmate because in fact the bishop can
sacrifice itself by moving to h3 then
you would just take the bishop and it
would be checkmate so what I was
inaccurate when I said but that move
Queen takes yeah that checkmate was a
pretty cool one right Queen takes g7
that was a pretty cool checkmate let me
set up one other very very very special
checkmate so this is a really famous
checkmating combination how many of you
have ever heard of a Lully the
magnificent I'll sue you guys don't know
else Uli the Magnificent one of the
greatest players of the 11th century was
al sully the magnificent now al Sully
was a poet and mathematician in the and
a storyteller he was also the greatest
chess player of the Arabian Court and al
su Li he played for the king and the
King would bet a lot of money on the
outcomes of the of the games and al su
Li the magnificent he gets his name for
a reason what was the reason he always
won and al su Li the Magnificent created
chess puzzles and today we see a lot of
the compositions of al su Lee the
Magnificent now keep in mind this guy
played 900 years ago
cool and he showed this kind of a
problem position and notice that black
is threatening checkmate correct yeah
and it's going to be virtually
impossible for white to defend checkmate
so black has it in his mind that he's
winning the game but there's a way
I'll sully the Magnificent shoda way for
white to save the game our young okay
just a second just a second in fact this
since the threat of checkmate is so
great and there's nothing we can do
about it
white has to be desperate so whatever
white does he have to do with check so
the knight comes to e7 with a check to
blacks King blacks King has no choice it
goes to the corner young man
yes and back yes beautiful move how many
of you want to give up your queen for a
pond okay but this move is the best move
Queen takes h7 check I'm showing you all
of these ways to sacrifice your queen
you should be worried but this was a
deal yeah I guess I would win when I'm a
queen down I love my queen I couldn't
play when I didn't have a queen Queen
takes h7 check Black has no choice he
must recapture the Queen he recaptures
the Queen and now young man
rook h1 how is that if that a cool make
check mating pattern whoa
but this check mating pattern of Queen
h7 is really one of my favorites and
what I would do is when I saw these
check mating patterns I had a little
notebook that you know if the it's the
ring book you you can kind of pop it
open and you add pages so I would make
sections in my notebook and one of my
notebooks the sections I would make is
Czech mating patterns so I learned Czech
mating patterns like the back rank
checkmate two bishops checkmate two
Knights checkmate rook and Knight and
I'd have them all listed out I also
studied combinations checkmating
combinations and I would like to show
you one last one and I think it's one of
the most beautiful checkmating
combinations in the world the following
check mating pattern is called the Gauls
mate okay the Gauls mate and it's a
really I think it's beautiful it's my
it's one of my favorite patterns and I
just want to show you how it goes and
it's it's black unfortunately black has
to play badly to lose Tula Gauls mate
this is a silly move black should be
developing any one of this pieces so
that's a bad move but it's important for
it's almost like for you to win a game
your opponent has to make a mistake
right so we're getting close to the
setup and when my teacher showed me this
llegaste it's like I got a big smile I
ran home I told my mom she said very
good let's you do your homework she
wasn't impressed but I was
the opponent plays Bishop g4 which on a
parent's sake is a really strong move
because it pins the knight to the Queen
so this knight moves the Queen young men
exactly and that's the set the start of
llegaste so basically to lose the game
black has to make two mistakes and in
this position my teacher he showed me
this move Knight takes e5 and I thought
this was a ridiculous move I said I
can't take that pawn with my knight I'm
afraid I will lose my queen and that's
exactly what happened I lost the Queen
now what should white play turn
Zack Lee Bishop takes f7 check the King
cannot move to the square d7 because
that square is protected by the knight
the King cannot take the bishop because
the bishops protected by the knight
there's nowhere else for the King to
move except up the board to e7 and as
Charlie says all white nile needs to do
is to be able to check blacks King and
the beautiful move is Knight to e5
checkmate
look how pretty that is these three
white pieces attack and control the
whole board black has virtually his
entire army in his checkmated